the flip side so a common complaint i
hear from guys is women say they want
the emotional side from us like they say
they want us to cry in front of them
they say they want it but then we give
it to them
and they're not attracted to it and they
don't like it so women don't really know
what they want exactly do you think
that's true
i've seen that i saw i saw that in a
video it was this guy
uh i don't know what he was upset about
or crying about but um the girl was like
she was on the phone with him and she
was like i want you to be more
vulnerable with me but not like this and
he's like pouring out his heart yeah
just confiding in her and then i thought
about like what you just asked us like
where's there like a cut-off to where
it's like okay i want you to be
vulnerable but not that long before you
look like a baby but it's like but like
where does it like stop i was gonna say
i think it depends on the situation at
all times because if i see you
crying over somebody dying or like
feeling like the way like the weight on
your shoulders is too much like i want
to be there for you to help you lift
that weight off your shoulders and make
you feel exactly but
if you see a rat in the corner of the
room and you start crying yeah i'm gonna
let me know like no because even i'm not
going to do that like i do
i feel like i'm crying as well so i'd be
like no i'll be crying but i fall out
man the hell up like yeah oh yeah yeah
can you just
like handle this
business yeah yeah just personal
preference like what are you attracted
to yeah like i know i definitely have
internalized like toxic masculinity like
i am very like
when a guy shows me like little signs of
like being like
a little feminine that's a huge turnoff
i like it
oh my gosh no i see a man on a crop top
oh no
it is not toxic masculinity to have a
preference for men that are men can i'm
sorry i'm sorry so
i'm not any less a man just because
they're just i
think you're more masculine am i a man
just because i'm wearing pants ooh are
you a what is that i am i don't know
when because i wear pants well i do yeah
pants are more masculine basketball
shorts are more matte like you look more
masculine when you wear that stuff men
tend to be more expensive
upset for that like why does it yeah if
you wear the baggy shorts like
basketball kit wise why does it mean i'm
more masculine do you know what i mean
because you look like like it's like
common sense
that's not coming to be like you know me
i could wear a salmon shirt
with blue jeans and just
a salmon pink shirt that means i'm
feminine well i mean not just a pink
shirt it's like how you dress like i
think it's common sense that a girl in a
ball gown looks more feminine and a girl
in a basketball jersey i think it looks
more massive
i don't i don't think it's security i
think it's common sense like i think
like come on you guys know what i'm
saying is true
you're telling me you're telling me
cinderella cinderella
looks more masculine
than a wnba player
no we get you come on
but i
are you just that with a men's sport
yeah it's more matte like girls look
more masculine in our basketball journey
i wear them i wear them she's saying
that just the look like they're you know
i understand what you're saying
so if a guy comes to me in a crop top he
looks more feminine i'm not attracted to
elliott looks real good
wait wait there are exceptions to
everywhere
it comes in a football kit you'll be
saying oh i look more masculine yeah
yeah because typically
that is
but like
the world we live in see this is where
society's standards come in i thought
personally to my in my opinion your
opinions don't i don't don't get yeah
it's wrong yeah i just feel like
personally we're in a world that's more
evolved where back in the day yes
football and basketball are sports
that's more associated with
men
and women have worked their asses off
their bloody asses of i'm trying not to
swear guys
um to get to where they are the level of
where they are for example i haven't had
an argument with a guy that said one of
the girls on your team um plays like a
guy and i argued with him and i was like
yo why does she play many times
why
like statistically in every category in
every sorry physically scientifically
yeah quickly so by every measure that
you get every piece of data that you can
measure and then women muscles and their
muscles
it's on a different level okay
this girl worked her ass off to get to
the standard of basketball uh-huh that
she plays she's a pro player yeah yeah
and the guy said she plays like a guy
that's so degrading she worked her ass
off to get to where she plays i think
that's degrading but she looks like a
woman is that something she doesn't know
who she is it's not even about women or
men but why is it why is it degrading if
men are bad like they're better because
why would you compare me to americans
that's a whole different level matter
men are okay okay okay okay this is this
is this is this is
men are not in the conversation when
with that kind of thing like her working
her ass off and getting to that point
like to bring a man into that it's
almost like why because it was like why
doesn't
it why wait okay okay this is my
platform this is my this is my youtube
show pipe down child respectfully
like why does it matter like why is your
first instinct to get angry when men are
or like if we compare if we compare men
to women like they don't get angry like
why is your personality
so because they
[Music]
i'm saying like like basketball right
men statistically and every single i'm
sorry it's not a fun reality but
statistically like like in every single
category are better than women like
there's
like really good high school teams that
beat wnba teams all the time
like
but we we want credit yeah good we want
we could cut out the comparison of being
seen as a man so what if what if i said
you play what if i say you play like
lebron james would you be offended no
because
so
i wouldn't i wouldn't be offended but
i'd be like so
my
my gifts and my talents are overlooked
to be compared to
an nba player yes
great nba player but i'd be like can i
not be can i not play like jessica can i
not play like me i gotta understand what
you're saying but just the fact that
women can't be be like oh she's a great
player she she plays like herself like i
wonder how long she took the train blah
blah to get there but to be compared to
a man it's like okay why can't i why
can't i give you compared to lisa
i just don't understand why it's a bad
thing if they're if they're good like
we just i don't i don't think about it
as women like me personally i can say i
got complimented in the comparison of a
woman right and that was the best
feeling in the world because i was
playing beach volleyball one day yeah
and this guy on the court was like oh
you're black serena williams but in
volleyball yeah i was like
you you but you weren't offended by that
because because she was a woman and she
paved away for female 1 but i'm saying
like a man did not pave away for us we
did
okay women were doing it for me
like in the in college basketball
women's take losses every year in
profits who's making the profits
that's paving the way
they lose money every single year when
it comes to money i mean just being
strong enough to want to play a sport
that is male dominated for example like
come on tennis
uh basketball all those things
it always started out with men at some
point they were like all right let's let
women play even baseball they decided
not to let women play baseball and
called it softball yeah like because
they decided to be different like don't
the only time i feel like it's okay to
make extreme
comparisons and differences in the sport
is track that makes sense women are
naturally built different we fully
accept that
so we have to make those exceptions for
us and track but in other sports give
women a little bit more credit you know
we we haul ass too
so they hold it down
yeah like if we look at there's a lot of
women there's a lot of female like if
we're going to talk about basketball or
anything i can't be coming to volleyball
i don't really pay attention to it like
that but like even in basketball um even
football
there's a lot of female players that
actually play better than a lot of men
plays but you never say you never catch
like a other guy crediting them like
that like but
wait are you talking about soccer yeah
yeah are you talking about soccer
but if the women if
it's all driven by the market though
like it's driven by by the fans that
want to watch so so if if women were
better than men like more fans would
watch they would make more money
later way better is like not the right
term like i think that
like historically like male sports have
dominated and that's kind of the tone
that's set like yeah we can have like a
40-year yeah exactly right also women we
don't play like men we play differently
we're correct yes business and that's
genetics yeah we are like
volleyball it's completely different
because men's volleyball yeah yeah
women's volleyball is a lot less like
men's volleyball they'll have two
rallies and then it's over because
everyone hits so hard that you can only
do so much with it yeah women's
volleyball is a lot different and that
like there's a lack of interest like
women's basketball you're not going to
see girls dunking every single ball
right
that's not the showboat like you know
what i'm saying so yeah yeah i'm like i
agree i agree yeah i don't appreciate
the i think it's about
tactics i think
i think it's because like
obviously men are gonna be better
because testosterone is a thing yeah and
they just have more it's also what makes
them more emotional fun facts yeah i saw
that on this again and so
but i think it's just the point of like
we we already know men are going to be
physically more better than yeah but why
do we have to have that comparison they
may be a great player they may be a
great athlete but why can't there's also
great athletes as women why can't i be
compared to a woman why do i have to be
compared to a man and so i think i'd
rather be compared to a guy in
basketball because they're better but
they're like but there's great but
there's no i'm mad like if they said you
play like like lebron james i'd be like
dope that's the best basketball player
in the world like emo that's
no i would pick lebron he's better small
person
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah completely your opinion yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying it's fine it
doesn't like matter
yeah yeah i know that when i was a
teenager and i first started in
volleyball like i was constantly
compared to guys yeah like initially
because i had a very masculine and
aggressive way of playing as opposed to
just straight tactics so it makes sense
but i did take it as a compliment like i
never had an issue with it because i was
just like gang [ __ ] like yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah
like that look at these muscles
like this
but
when it came to a point where i realized
like
men don't have to be the pinnacle of
power like that's what it is like i'm
a little tired of that narrative like i
want i don't see it i don't think it's
the narrative i see women in media all
the time
like i see women in like and and
online it's changing i see women
definitely yeah so i don't i don't see
men as being like the pinnacle of like
80 of consumer buying decisions are by
women so we're all like we are
constantly being marketed for women i
feel like i'm just tired of like okay
like when you look at like commercials
in the way that um sports are showed
with like men for example it's always
like them with gatorade and they're like
yeah yeah feel the burn like not really
like you see a tampax commercial and
it's like damn bro like more than our
periods please you can do your whole
life on your period the only time that
you see again like i mentioned before
serena williams like that's like one of
the only athletes that you see in these
commercials like going hard and going
big and it's not about your travel
girlfriend track was just in it the girl
from the track team was just in it
the us the us sorry i haven't simone
like
no she's not from track wait wait i
can't simone
i was just saying that like they're like
like serena williams like she is so
overly sexualized because she has like a
big ass and she's like a curvy girl and
she's attractive like that bothers me
too because it's like it doesn't focus
on her skill she's insane
oh she is
like sexualized in a tennis match it's
like okay i'm gonna start sexualizing
men your balls look real good jiggly
touching on that there was a coach i
can't remember where she was from but it
was breast cancer awareness and she had
on pink leather pants and a white top
nothing good she looked great but
someone said is this inappropriate for a
coach i'm like why is that what is it
what if a dude wore tight pants and you
could see stuff and like is that
inappropriate i hate to bring in racism
it's also a racial thing oftentimes
they have always sexualized black women
and at the same time masculinize us it
makes no sense and then discriminates
against it it's like what do you want
because you know you really want all of
that
if you're going to constantly sexualize
us like get it together dog like we are
not just
i don't know i don't care
okay wait so the next the next
appreciate so